So, what should you use if you need
a complex data storage system? Well, there's one more
system, the Indexed Database API, also called IndexedDB for
short. Indexed Database was designed in response to Web
SQL, and its SQLite variant. Indexed Database is
not a SQL API, it's a simpler index storage
system, on which you can build an optimized query
implementation, like a, a SQL variant. This means it
isn't optimized to a particular query system. Instead, when
you create your database, you define what indexes you want
to use. If you've never done database storage before,
IndexDB may take a little bit of getting used to,
but it's actually pretty straight forward. The spec itself
has some really good examples in it. This code is
based on the spec. FIrst, you need to open
your database and you need to be prepared to initialize
the database if it hasn't been opened before. When you
initialize the database, you can define the indexes in the
database, that is, what attributes are easily searchable. You can
change this later too, you just have to upgrade the database.
And of course you can inspect the databases in the
developer tools to see what's going in to the IndexDB store.
And check to make sure it's organized the way you
want it. Just go into the Resources tab, select IndexDB, and
there you go. You can see your objects right there.
If you expand them, you can even see the values.